Florian Engel is a classic car
enthusiast
he's taking something really special out
of his garage and the Bavarian town of
one siedel nearby white
it's a 1973 Corolla Levine Toyota
introduced a second version of the
Corolla in Japan in 1970 a year later
the Corolla was marketed in Germany and
sold 20,000 models it was yet another
success for the Japanese car industry
abroad but the Levine model which is
like the GTI of Corollas was only
available for customers in Japan and the
US
Florian ENGOs Levine is probably the
only one in Germany or even Europe he
found it on an American car forum and
convinced the owner to sell him the rare
model even though the car is a decade
older than its owner the Levine's
4-cylinder 1.6 liter engine still powers
it up to 108 horsepower and a top speed
of 183 on the Autobahn the Corollas line
seemed a bit odd yet somehow familiar
it's a typical compact car with European
dimensions some say the design is
reminiscent of the Ford Escort others
say it's more like an Opel cadet a few
of the details are a bit too quirky
Florian says when he takes the car to
old timer events few people recognize it
as a Toyota there's little to reveal
what it is except for the old Toyota
badge on the grille it says Corolla on
the side that's when people realise what
it is the Corolla was supposed to
conquer new markets for Toyota
some say that explains its aesthetic the
curvy fastback rear end is reminiscent
of American muscle cars downscaled just
slightly a full family of Corolla models
were made a sedan station wagon and a
sporty two-door known to insiders as te
27 florian says that when he looks at
the TE 27 he sees that its design has
been influenced by a wide range of cars
it's like that with most Japanese autos
he says the thing that makes it special
is that it's a mix of all types of
styles and as a result has created
something new it's not like Italian cars
that always originate their own lines
but a combination is it coming off the
oil the interior by contrast is quite
Spartan there are a few sporty
accessories like a rev counter which was
a contemporary feature there's lots of
plastic with a hint of chrome nothing
flashy to distract from the driving
experience
the advantage of the sparse interior
trim what's not there
can't break florian says that you really
have to be passionate about Japanese
cars because getting spare parts for
them takes patience there are still
parts in Japan and the American market
for them is big but fluorine says in
Germany it's difficult to get parts here
when something breaks tight it's a clean
venomous couple toes thank goodness
there's very little that breaks when it
comes to large series classics that are
made in Japan the Corolla Levine is
robust Florian can simply focus on the
joy of driving it Lavie means lightning
bolt and refers to the cars driving
performance the little car from Japan
doesn't have to hide its light under a
stone it weighs 850 kilograms and goes
from 0 to 100 kilometers an hour in 9
seconds the chassis technology is solid
rigid axle suspended with leaf springs
were standard in compact car
construction in the 1970s
the Corolla showpiece is under the hood
to double barrel carburetors ensure that
the dual overhead cam straight
4-cylinder 1.6 liter engine purrs with
power modeled on Alfa Romeos of the time
motorcycle manufacturer Yamaha supported
Toyota and developing the cylinder head
the growl lets everyone know the Corolla
isn't just cute Florian became a Toyota
fan early on his grandfather founded one
of the first Toyota outlets in Germany
in 1975 Florian's dad and uncle
Friedhelm
later took over the company in the 1980s
in addition to selling maintaining and
repairing current Toyota models Toyota
specialist Friedhelm Engel has got a
side job he restores classic cars
most of them vintage Toyotas this green
silica is about finished it's being
completely rebuilt for his own
collection
if Florian has a problem or can't get
apart
uncle fleet home always has a solution
the area around home has plenty of
sinuous roads making it perfect driving
territory for Florian angle in his
levine he loves going out for rides in
his rare vehicle
and there's one thing the Toyota fan can
be certain of it's not likely he'll run
into someone with a car like his anytime
soon